Connie Brock when Hollywood had a king
is about what person it's actually about
two people but the king is Lew Wasserman
and and I say to people because Jule
Styne was the person who gave him his
chance and really set up the business
the platform from which he was launched
but it's Lew Wasserman whose Jule Styne
Jule Styne started the music Corporation
of America a band booking agency in
Chicago in 1924 in Al Capone's Chicago
and it was from that company that
eventually Wasserman was launched
because this is a political network the
first thing I want to connect is that
Katrina vanden Heuvel
is his granddaughter is jules Stein's
granddaughter yes and she's with the
nation the editor and all that was Jill
Stein was a Republican a right-wing
Republican explain all that connection
and how does you know where does the
vanden Heuvel come in in all this well
Jules had two daughters Jean and Susan
and Jean is the mother of Jean Stein is
the mother of Katrina and Jean was
always her politics are always different
than her father's and it was a source of
great friction between them and I mean
Jules was very proud of her she was very
accomplished person but but their
politics were just polar opposites
really and Katrina followed in her
mother's footsteps what was it that Jill
Stein started in MCA what did they do it
was a band booking agency in Chicago in
the days when Chicago was controlled by
an Al Capone and Stein basically turned
the he turned the one he he turned the
band booking business into a business it
had never really been a business before
fans were usually booked for one-night
stands and Stein came up with the idea
that if they traveled then they would
need an agent to arrange all these
travels and so it was a simple idea but
quite brilliant and he
put into effect and within within less
than ten years he controlled 90% of the
bands in America he then decided that
bands were actually going to dance bands
were on the decline although you
couldn't see it yet in the figures but
he saw that it wasn't going to be a
thriving business for too much longer
and so he decided to move MCA the music
Corporation of America which now he
called MCA to Hollywood and move into
the the talent agency business booking
stars for movies and so he did that in
1936 and really that's where that's
where Wasserman story begins now here's
a picture of little Wasserman I think in
1958 who was he Lew Wasserman was a
really poor kid from Cleveland who had
to work through from junior high school
on as an usher in movie theaters and he
then was a publicist for nightclubs in
Cleveland he wanted to go to college he
couldn't afford to he was a publicist
for nightclubs and as a publicist he
would get some advertising advertising
circulars from the Music Corporation of
America and he didn't think they were
very good so he would redo them for his
nightclubs his night clubs would be
booking MCAS bands and Jule Stein's
brother Bill heard about this guy Lou
who never thought their advertising was
good enough and he got to meet him and
he brought him to Chicago eventually to
meet Jule Styne he was 23 at the time
why did you get interested in these two
characters I got interested really in
Wasserman because I interviewed him in
91 when MCA was sold to Matsushita I did
a long piece for The New Yorker about
that transaction and the personalities
involved in it and at that time I came
to realize that Wasserman was a
fascinating figure and immensely
powerful for around 50 years he was
clearly the most powerful man in
Hollywood he
influenced virtually everything that
happened in that community and it went
beyond Hollywood because it was since he
wanted to control that world it meant
that he had to be able to control labor
situations he had to have a strong
influence in national politics he had to
have a kind of liaison with the mob so
it was a way of telling through one
person a much larger story that reached
into all these areas and I thought it
would be really fascinating and I didn't
really know another I always have wanted
to tell a much larger story through an
individual and I couldn't think of any
other individual through whom I could
tell a story of this scope and also I
mean that the fact that the arc went
from four wasserman from the 30s until
just heat when he died a year ago Jill
Stein lived for how long when did he die
he lived to be 85
he died in 1981 there's a picture all in
one that I could find in the book on
page 199 of Sidney Korshak
who was he Sidney Korshak was the
Chicago mobs man in Hollywood he started
out in life in in his professional life
as a lawyer it's pretty clear as a
lawyer for Capone that's what he told
friends of his in any event and he got
involved with the Chicago Outfit at that
time this is about 1931 or so and he
then went on eventually to move to
Hollywood where he was the the mobs man
and he had enormous influence on labor
unions the Teamsters especially so for
Wasserman the it was it was a
relationship that mirrored the one Stein
had established earlier in in Chicago
Stein had had a relationship with
Petrillo who was the head of the
Musicians Union and also connected to Al
Capone and then Wasserman in Hollywood
had korshack who among many other things
enabled him to have great relationships
with the Teamsters on the back of your
book
quote on Lew Wasserman he helped me
become president he helped me stay
president he helped me be a better
president Bill Clinton well Wasserman
decided that he wanted Hollywood to be a
more potent political force than that
had ever been before he in part came to
that decision because in 1962 the
Justice Department Bobby Kennedy's
Justice Department brought an antitrust
action against MCA which the settlement
of which caused them to go out of the
talent agency business and only be in
the production business and while
Wasserman actually didn't mind that it
kind of suited his what he what he
wanted to do still he didn't like being
forced to do it as he was and he decided
that he never wanted to be in a position
where the government could have that
kind of impact on him again or he wanted
to try not to be in such a position so
he decided to make Hollywood a really
potent force in Washington and he built
a fundraising machine such as had not
existed in Hollywood before and he
became he became really he was somebody
who could call any President on the
phone his relationship he began by
raising money for for JFK but he wasn't
he was never close to JFK but then with
with Johnson he found somebody whom he
really admired enormous Lee and felt
close to and after that had continued I
mean Nixon he wasn't so close to but
there was a Republican at MCA who who
had the relationship with Nixon and then
Reagan well Wasserman had been his agent
back starting in 1939 so they had a
relationship over decades of great
reciprocity and Clinton Wasserman was
crazy about I remember he said to me you
know don't get me started on Bill
Clinton else I'll sound like a lovesick
teenager connect the Connie Brooke dots
for me you have been in New York you're
married to a former congressman who was
here in Washington for a while but you
live in Los Angeles when did all explain
all that where did you start and
professionally well I've always in my
life lived in New York my professional
life I lived there basically forever in
California briefly when I was really
young but then New York I started out as
a reporter at the American Lawyer
magazine and then I wrote a book about
Michael Milken called the Predators ball
and with that Bob Gottlieb hired me at
The New Yorker to be their business
writer by the way the Predators ball
came out what year I think it was 1988
and I really well I didn't know too much
about business I mean I I knew what I
wrote about Milken but I wasn't really a
business writer per se but but Gottlieb
thought that I was based on that book he
he didn't know much about business
either and so he brought me in as than
the Orcas business writer and then when
Tina Brown came in she freed me to write
about other subjects as well I wrote
about politics more under Tina you've
written major pieces on Hillary Clinton
and Newt Gingrich a book on Steve Ross
who was head of Warner right and in what
years were all those done well the book
on Ross I guess I mean that was master
of the game which came out in 1994 and I
had written pieces about Time Warner at
The New Yorker that was how I got
interested in Ross and at the same time
it and then in the early 90s I wrote the
piece about Hillary and then about
Gingrich and then after that I wrote
about the Middle East so Tina was the
one who let me sort of just have a
broader ambit when did you marry
congressman is it mellow vine or vanilla
by the vine just two years ago and but I
had been living in California with him
more or less sort of the last five years
so and it was in that period of time
that I was working on this book the mob
the gangsters all that it pops up in
your book all the way through this any
evidence that any of these people like
Lew Wasserman or Jill Steiner and the
people at MCA were ever part of the mob
in any way I wouldn't say part of the
mob I mean I think that they lived in a
time when well certainly Jules lived in
a time when in order to be in the
business he was in he really had to
have good relations with the mob and he
was I mean it was more than that he was
he was their partner I was fortunate to
meet judge Mayer Yvette's Abraham
Lincoln Mehra vets in Chicago who had
been who was alive and active in that
time the same period as Jules and he
knew Jules he knew Capone he knew
Petrillo who was the head of the
Musicians Union and it was he who told
me that Jules had had an interest in the
Chez Paree which was a nightclub run by
the mob and so Jules was partners with
the mob but as I say at that time I
don't think he could he couldn't have
been as successful in the business he
was in and maybe he couldn't even have
been in the business he was in if he
didn't have these relationships for a
Wasserman I don't know whether he had to
but it was certainly uniquely useful to
have the relationship with Sidney
Korshak who as I said helped him in his
relationship with the unions and the
unions are totally key to the movie
business and he also was a kind of
all-around fixer in Hollywood why are
the unions key to the movie business
well because they can kill it if you you
know if you have a strike and you and
and you have a movie and doesn't you
they just stopped the business and also
in the TV business which was Wasserman
what he moved into even before he got
into the movie business he was in TV
production he was even more dependent on
the union's because of the short lead
time I mean they could be even more
destructive so he and Wasserman he
understood that he had come into the
business at a time when relations
between the studio heads and the unions
were terrible there are horrible strikes
in the mid 30s and then and then a very
bad strike in 1946 so he fully
appreciated what bad labor relations
could do to him as a studio head and he
went about making sure every way he
could that he would have labor peace how
much evidence was there that the mob was
involved in the Teamsters Union well it
was pretty clear because the Teamsters
union from the 50s on was headed by
Jimmy Hoffa
and he was definitely I mean it's been
established that he was closely relay
was controlled by the mob really and
Sidney Korshak who was the Chicago mobs
guy was very close to Jimmy Hoffa so
there wasn't any question really that
the mob controlled the Teamsters in that
period of time what was the what is the
mob
well the mob was an organization that I
mean it had different parts there I mean
the part that I concentrated on this
book was the Chicago mob because that
was where Joel Stein started and that
was where his relationships were and
then it was it was the Chicago mob that
sent Korshak to Hollywood and also
earlier be often Brown they had they
were sent from the Chicago mob and
basically it was a scheme in the 30s to
try to take over or have a large
interest in the studio's so the Chicago
mob was one distinct entity and then
there were the New York families but
those didn't have so much to do with the
story that I tell politics I'm jumping
to chapter three which is political
might before I show a picture your MCA
had Universal Studios which made what
kind of movies what are the big movies
that they make jaws et Back to the
Future those are Spielberg I mean
Spielberg was by far their greatest
director and really the driving force of
their movie business I would say but you
go back to 1960 you say that Lew
Wasserman really didn't like Jack
Kennedy that much how much was that due
to the fact that his brother Bobby was
an investigator in Congress with a mob
it was due I think to a considerable
degree because Bobby Kennedy was
investing was going after he was very
focused on Las Vegas and Vegas was a
place where MCA did a lot of business
and where Wasserman had personal
relationships as well Moe Dalitz
Wasserman had known from Cleveland it
was very close to him and Moe Dalitz was
really the he was
called The Godfather of Las Vegas he had
the desert in so and Dalitz was on Bobby
Kennedy's top forty hoodlums list I mean
Dale it's hated Kennedy so I think that
it's I think it's true that Wasserman
didn't like the Kennedys because in part
at least because Bobby Kennedy was going
after people like Dallas and also Sidney
Korshak there's a picture at the
beginning of this chapter three and at
our back is Lyndon Johnson it looks like
the dining room on the first floor of
the White House you've got on the left
there Lew Wasserman Arthur Krim Bob
Benjamin lots of other names and at the
very far end Tom Johnson it was the
deputy press secretary at the time why
this picture and why Lyndon Johnson oh
well that picture I love that picture
because Wasserman was really crazy about
LBJ and definitely was closer to him
than to any other president and and
Wasserman is right there at his left and
Wasserman always said that Johnson had
offered him the position of Secretary of
Commerce ultimately I came to believe
that that was not true that he had
actually offered it to him I think there
was some suggestion about it but I don't
believe that it was ever offered but
that became part of Wasserman's well it
was very important to Wasserman first of
all to have this political influence as
a reality and also to be able to sort of
trade on that I mean it it it enhanced
his aura the fact that he was friend to
presidents and the fact that he could
say also that Johnson was not only
someone whom he could get on the phone
and whom he saw and was invited to the
White House many homes but the Johnson
had offered him a cabinet position just
elevated him obviously even more you
suggest I think that that fact or that
suggestion that he was offered the
Secretary of Commerce might have come
from Jack Valenti
it was Valenti who first said it in a
public context and was quoted in variety
or Hollywood Reporter in 1974 and then
after that after that both Valenti and
Wasserman made reference to it
many many many times Wasserman always
said that he had been offered that he
told me he had been offered he told me
many times he'd been offered the job he
didn't he didn't do it because his wife
didn't want to move to Washington and
Valente also said that Johnson had
offered to him fealty told me that a
number of times so why would they both
said it I thought they both said it
after LBJ had died what was the
relationship then between Hollywood and
LBJ Hollywood and Nixon nalli you're
down the list about what what did
Hollywood want from the president and
what did these presidential candidates
want from Hollywood
well the presidential candidates wanted
money not surprisingly and there was a
lot of it to be gotten and it was not I
mean it was money but it was also even
more than that I mean it was it was the
power it was star power they could have
celebrities come to Washington and
testify if there were things that they
wanted but basically fundraisers out in
Hollywood celebrities there that was
what it was an enormous amount of money
that was available for them to tap and
for Hollywood naturally they wanted
legislation that would be useful to them
and that would make the business more
profitable which which they were able to
obtain most notably Nixon really paved
the way for the investment tax credit
which was worth billions to the industry
and it's not I mean it's a little known
that Nixon was such a friend to
Hollywood but he was the he was except
for Reagan he might have been the
greatest friend to Hollywood with the
possible exception of Reagan Reagan when
the financial interest syndication rules
were going to be repealed in the early
eighties rules which restricted TV
networks ability to have ownership of
their programming and therefore were a
bonanza for the movie studios which did
have the ownership those rules were
going to be repealed and basically lost
him and talked to Reagan and Reagan
called off his chairman of the FCC and
the hill moved to repeal them was
stopped in its tracks now you do quote I
think Martin Fowler who was chairman
see see is saying that didn't happen
it's true that Fowler denied that that
had happened because one of your stories
is that the White House has control over
these agencies like the Federal
Communications Commission right well the
actually the the FCC is supposed to be
an independent agency but I'm told by
enough people that I believe that it's
true that Fowler was talked to by Reagan
and then he reversed he did reverse his
position there's no question that he
reversed his position because he had
made his position public and then he
reversed it and I guess he would say he
did it on the merits here's a picture of
Walter Pidgeon and Ronald Reagan do you
remember what year this might have been
well I don't it was Walter Pidgeon yeah
Walter Pidgeon was a an actor who was
very very successful maybe many of our
watchers remember him but very
successful in the 40s 50s 60s and he was
important in this story because when
Wasserman wanted to go into the TV
production business he was already MCA
was the most powerful agency by far they
represented
oh just mmm 80% of the big stars you
name them Betty Davis Joan Crawford
Jimmy Stewart Clark Gable on and on he
wanted to go into the TV production
business as well and he saw while the
the studio heads were afraid of
television because they felt that it was
just going to threaten their business
Wasserman stole that it was opportunity
but he needed a waiver from the Screen
Actors Guild in order to be able to be
both a producer and a talent agent
Reagan was the president of the Screen
Actors Guild at that time and Walter
Pidgeon was on the board and there was a
critical meeting where the issue came up
of whether this waiver would be given to
MCA or not and Pidgeon made an
impassioned speech about how it should
be done because it would just give them
more jobs and why shouldn't they do it
and so forth and and Pidgeon was
somebody whom everybody loved and
respected many many of the people on the
Screen Actors Guild board did so the
resolution passed but really
I've been told and people believe really
it was Reagan who engineered it even
though it was pigeon who gave the speech
dead have you gotten any in size you did
this book from your husband it was a
former congressman and he represents
Hollywood when he was there alibi he did
he had a good relationship with Lew
Wasserman who was an important supporter
of his I mean do you get one of the
underlying themes in this book is this
money
Hollywood Washington thing I mean is
there anything illegal in any of this
there is nothing illegal that no there's
nothing illegal that I mean I mean did
you did your cynicism level go up at all
when you're doing this book well I mean
it didn't really surprise me that people
who were really massive contributors can
get Congress to pass legislation that
benefits them I I don't think I mean
obviously it's never supposed to be a
quid pro quo but Wasserman had such
power that I'm John Tunney told me a
story about when he was raising money
for I guess this was in 76 former
senator from California senator from
California right and Wasserman had he
had known Wasserman they had had a good
relationship Westerman that had helped
him in his first run he wanted whenever
asked anything of him they would have
breakfast they would have meals together
Wasserman wanted to discuss things like
education and different you know
domestic policy and never asked anything
of him but Tony got a call from
Wasserman one day and the fall of 76
saying that he needed him but Tony was
in California for a dinner which was
very important to him a big fundraising
dinner in San Francisco Wasserman said
he had needed him that he had to go back
to Washington because there was a
critical moment in the vote on the
investment tax credit and Tony said I
can't I have this dinner and said he
wouldn't and then he thought about it
for I don't know three minutes him he
called Mossman back and he said okay I'm
going and he turned around and didn't go
to his dinner and went back to
Washington and as he recounted the story
to me later he said really I had no
choice why because he couldn't
he couldn't have risked engaging the
wrath of Wasserman I mean Wasserman
would have not supported him and would
have blocked other people from
supporting him and he needed he couldn't
have he couldn't afford to lose
Hollywood support in his fundraising for
his campaign I wrote a bunch of stuff
that you wrote about the Watchmen down
white shirt and dark tie all the time
all the time and he also made it a
uniform it was there was a dress code at
MCA they wanted to Jule Styne started
this before Wasserman but they they
believed that it was important they
wanted to sort of elevate the image of
talent agents and make them seem more
professional and so 'angels was actually
an ophthalmologist by training so he he
wanted to sort of upgrade the image and
so it was a strict dress code in the
early days of MCA everybody had to wear
a dark suit white shirt dark tie in
later years it it eased up slightly
maybe you could wear you know a blue
shirt but that was the that was the
dress code and also Wasserman always
dressed that way and even if there
hadn't been a dress code his people were
so kind of imbued with his stature as a
leader that they tended to mimic him
even to the slightest thing as somebody
pointed out to me and MCA point out to
me years later he pointed to his black
loafers and they said you know they
didn't have to wear black loafers
but loaded and and the rest of them
followed suit did you see any evidence
of its photographic memory well I I
didn't I have to say because when I
spoke to him first time I interviewed
him was in 91 and then for this book I
interviewed him over the course of the
last well you know 98 to the time he
died basically in 2002 so I didn't see a
photographic memory
his memory was still quite good and
amazing for someone who was in his you
know mid to late 80s
but I didn't see the photographic memory
lots of other stuff you say you never
take him on people never took him out
right right that was what I was told
again and again that no one no one who
worked for him would take him on they
were tough guys Sonny Werblin in the MCA
office in New York was a tough tough guy
smart but nobody would take wants him
anon he was apparently just too
intimidating too formidable and too
intimidating didn't exercise didn't
exert himself to smile had a dry sense
of humor a little sleep never committed
anything to paper any of those you want
to explain well returned all his calls
right he returned all his calls
the same day which was pretty remarkable
he never he didn't believe in committing
things to paper that was and that was
something which you know somebody swifty
Lazar once commented that MCA was a lot
like the Mafia and in that regard whilst
Herrmann was very similar to his friend
Sidney Korshak and others those guys
always know that you didn't commit
anything to paper Korshak would write on
the bench of bank of a matchbook cover
sometimes if he really had to remembers
you know some some deal a Jess truck and
Wasserman believed in that - he told me
he was very proud of when the government
sued MCA in 1962 that he only had four
folder files in his office
explosive tirades people would would
pass out that's true I I was told that
men would leave his office in tears
apparently it was unlike anything that I
I spoke to many people who said they had
worked for tough bosses or they had seen
they knew screamers and they knew but
this was different than that the sign
that it was coming Wasserman would take
his watch off and and then and then it
was
like a kind of a fit I'm told his voice
would go to a higher pitch than you
could imagine
and he would just scream and groan men
you know left his office crying or
fainting on occasion fainting it's hard
to imagine having never seen it but I
know that it occurred you say never had
any dances with other women and his wife
that you could find and that whenever a
woman was in his office as Secretary he
always kept a door open or had somebody
in there with him right as his secretary
said to me he didn't want anybody ever
to be able to say you know Lew Wasserman
chased me around his desk and and he was
I mean Hollywood were obviously many
people had such dalliance --is that
wasn't for him he was an ascetic kind of
a personality and really his focus was
the business and I don't think other
things I mean as far as I know that sort
of thing really didn't interest him but
you left us with some unanswered
questions on his wife is their name Edie
Edie and the suggestion was made in your
book that she had balances well I was
told this by many many people and that
was the reason that I included it in the
book even though one could I mean I
hesitated about including it but the
reason I did is because so many people
dozens of people told me that it was so
and that it not only was it so bitter it
was something that was just sort of
baffling and endlessly commented on in
the Hollywood community because people
could not understand how it was that the
most powerful man in Hollywood who
inspired such fear could not or would
not control his wife when he seemed to
control virtually everything else that
happened in that community and they also
questioned how anybody would have the
temerity to have an affair with
Wasserman's wife when he was such a
fearsome figure so it was something that
was just
it was bewildering and I never found an
answer to it and none of the people I
spoke to knew and answer to it people
had their theories you know he was so
involved with the business that he
didn't care because it just freed him so
we didn't have to think about anything
but the business but I mean people had
theories but nobody obviously knew what
the reason was but it was it was just it
was this mysterious thing that no one
really could make out so in after all
send and what did Hollywood get out of
London Johnson I'm not able to I I don't
I asked Lou that actually because I said
look with Nixon you got so much and LBJ
you were so much closer to and what did
you get from LBJ and he said well you
know if we didn't get anything then I
must not have asked him for anything
because I could have he got Jack Valenti
he did get Jack Valenti Valenti was
obviously was so close to Johnson and
and when the Motion Picture Association
of America was looking for a new head in
1966
Wasserman went to Johnson and said that
he wanted Valenti for it and and they
were different but there are different
versions about whether Johnson was
furious at the idea or whether really he
kind of liked the idea but in any event
Wasserman got Valenti and Valenti became
the head of the MPAA
position that he retains to this day
what was it Ted Sorensen story well
there was some consideration that
Johnson wanted to play Sorenson Sorenson
was going to leave the White House and
Johnson wanted to play Sorensen in the
MPAA because he felt that he would be
useful to him he could still write
speeches for him but on the other hand
he'd be in this organization which
Johnson recognized could be very
important to him but some people talked
to Sorenson and they said that they
would expect that he would also that his
first allegiance would be to the
president sort of beyond Cole to Johnson
and Sorensen as far as I didn't want to
do that in any event Sorensen Sorensen
rejected if I remember correctly there's
like seven movie houses at the time Jack
Valenti was made MPAA president and he
is probably to this day the most highly
paid lobbyist in town running one of
these organizations is that by design
that this the movie companies wanted the
highest paid lobbyist no I don't know if
that's true in fact I remember somebody
telling me that um that they thought
that Valenti wasn't paid enough Frank
you blonde who was the head of paramount
in the early 70s said that he thought
that Valenti should have been paid more
and but you know and I mean all these
guys were paid so much so I guess
they're you know their expectations are
just higher for what so someone ought to
be and volunteer was very important to
them so I think they thought he deserved
whatever he was getting it's hard to
make out everybody in this picture but
you have Richard Nixon who everybody
recognized and then tap Schreiber is in
this picture and Jack Valenti
you really can't see very well from here
but Taft Shriver played a role in your
book also why he was immensely important
as the Republican side of politics at
MCA Wasserman was the Democrat and Taft
Robert was the Republican and people
said actually there were there was a
sort of there was a considerable view
that that it wasn't that Wasserman was
such a true Democrat and that jewel that
really wants him an in Treiber could
have switched positions that there was
just such pragmatist they could have
just changed sides and done it the other
way but in any event Taff Jarboe was a
Republican and when Nixon became
president Schreiber was the one who took
over the relationship in with the
President and was the organizing person
in Hollywood for for the political
machine Wasserman was always there and
working hard but he was more in the
background at that point he let
Schreiber take the lead and Schreiber
organized this meeting in San Clemente
in 1971 which the people involved with
all the heads of the motion picture
studios and with Nixon and out of that
meeting came great things for for
Hollywood so Schreiber was immensely
important
at that point all right what what
overcame what did principal overcome
politics business overcome everything
else in the end I mean you had all these
Democrats in Hollywood
very few Republicans tax robbers are
probably most everybody else in the
movie business where Democrats giving
money to Richard Nixon right well I mean
they really I mean they did what must
have been told them to I mean there
wasn't any question that they weren't
going to give money and I don't think I
mean there was there wasn't a principle
involved in this I mean well I mean
principle in that personal political
beliefs versus we need this president
for business reasons and we'll give him
what I think that was it I think it came
down to the death I know that I mean
none of these Democrats refused to to do
it to give I mean they all gave even Lew
Wasserman I was told that he absolutely
gave though not in his name but I mean
the thing is too that the studios gave
you know down here on the mall as a
place called the Hirshhorn Museum right
Joseph Hirshorn how'd it get there it
got there because actually because Taft
Schreiber and Len garment were friends
of Hirshhorn and they lobbied Nixon to
be able to to that it should beat it in
that place on the mall and Hirshorn gave
quite a bit of money to Nixon was her
short a Republican or a Democrat you
know I believe he was a Democrat
although I remember there were some
conversations where they told Nixon that
if they cultivated him enough he thought
that he could perhaps become a
Republican back there you write on the
subject the Hirshhorn Museum Nixon
agreed without enthusiasm that it should
go forward but he insisted it should not
look like quote that horrible Whitney
thing in New York right
not that I'm anti-semitic laughter from
his visitors but you don't want an all
Jewish List garment responded well these
are the art experts I spoke to Taft
about the names the whole issue of being
Jewish
is all through this section with Richard
Nixon you've you've got your hands on
some tapes their public tapes where'd
you find him in the National Archives
did you listen to them I did I listened
to them a lot
did you transcribe them yourself or that
had they already trans I transcribed it
myself and what did you find
well I found these really interesting
conversations between Nixon and Haldeman
and Ehrlichman the thing about Nixon and
Jews is that he was very and it came up
in Hollywood because he saw a Hollywood
as mainly Jewish and he was it was for
him a sort of just a difficult mix he
resented Jews because he felt they were
mainly liberal and he it was a rant with
him about how you how little Jewish
support he got he was just endlessly
about that and so filled with resentment
on the other hand he had he appreciated
that holiday Hollywood could give him a
lot of money and he also felt a kind of
affinity for Hollywood he actually even
though he was this graceless guy he
obviously kind of liked Hollywood and
and was a little bit mesmerised by its
glamour so it was a mix for him and it
never really I mean I mean those tapes
show a lot of things that sound really
anti-semitic and you know Len garment
would defend him and say that it was
just that he was always so resentful
because he got so little Jewish support
well here's just one part in your book
it says referring to Jewish supporters
of Israel Haldeman it was his top aide
concluded there a ruthless Bunch they're
going to turn off the instant you don't
send them the signal the signal they
want and they'll stay on as long as they
think you're going to anything they
think they can pressure you into Bob
Haldeman seem to have a strong view
about Jews he did he did and I think
that I think his you seemed you know
worse than Nixon essentially because
Nixon at one point started to say Nixon
was cut was good on Israel I mean
1973 in the in the 1978 Yom Kippur War
Nixon sent the planes and armaments that
were vital for Israel so and I remember
Nixon saying to either Haldeman
Ehrlichman you know he was talking about
Kissinger and how Kissinger was so
pro-israel he said you know all these
Jews they you know if they're just
that's the way they are about Israel you
know that's just the way they are I've
never seen a Jew who isn't but he wasn't
he was saying it in a way as though as a
means of understanding how people felt
whereas held him ins statements just
sound frankly anti-semitic there was a
little nugget on page 296 that you have
and I'm not sure you got you might have
gotten from the Holliman transcripts
which he published himself a believer
his wife did I guess on Henry Kissinger
and the issue isn't Henry Kissinger has
been Bradley I know if you remember this
oh yeah
and I'll read it he K this is Bob
Haldeman speaking he came in and asked
what he ought to do about it and I said
just keep your damn mouth shut
he gave them an answer and that that'll
get you give him an answer that would
give him a story Ben Bradley called and
said there's a story about your dating
this girl who plays in x-rated movies
nude movies sex movies do you want us to
hold it for the time being because of
your trip Henry said yes in other words
does he or we didn't think that Ben
Bradley offered Henry Kissinger the
opportunity to hold a story because he
had a trip coming up according to
Halderman according to Holloman yeah did
you believe that I I did you think an
editor would say to someone like Henry
kitchen will hold this story out until
you get your trip out of it well I don't
know I don't know I mean that was
actually it would you have done that as
a reporter well no no but but no but I
don't know what the relationship was
between Bradley and it was at the
Washington Post and right right and
those tapes were at the National
Archives it wasn't held him and didn't
didn't release them so this has done
published before me what was the story
about Judy Brown oh she was some starlet
and Kissinger
Kissinger liked going to Hollywood and
dating these women he also had an affair
with Jill st. John around the same
period who was also involved Sidney was
involved with Sidney Korshak which made
it kind of much more dicey and Kissinger
seemed I thought naive about that at the
time that he would be having an affair
with the woman who was at the same time
course Shaq's mistress I thought showed
a certain degree of naivete did you by
chance happen to call Henry Kissinger
and ask him to verify and his stuff I
actually was supposed to see Kissinger I
ended up not being able to so it goes
the network suit that Hollywood wanted
explain that please in the Nixon
administration years
well Hollywood was just really really
one of the things that wanted more than
anything else was for the Justice
Department to prevent to sue the
network's and the Nixon wanted to sue
the network's because he hated them
because he felt that they had this we're
so against him and did I read from your
tape that you got her just so that you
get the full thrust of it right Nixon
says in this tape you've got and he's
talking to John Mitchell that's one of
the reasons I'm for at Taft Schreiber
the main reason I'm for it is I want to
screw the network's in any event they
got to be screwed they're terrible
people they're a bunch of bastards but
the movie people when we were in
California with Taft Schreiber I
promised him we'd do something oh no I'm
all for it this is purely political in
timing he's talking about wind it bring
the suit against the network right right
and so and ultimately he did bring the
suit against the network's and there was
some investigation by the Justice
Department about whether there was some
appearance that perhaps he had brought
it because of these contributions that
were coming in from Hollywood but
ultimately that was never proven how
much money did
I would give Richard Nixon oh I don't
remember the exact amount but I mean
you're talking hundreds of thousands of
dollars oh for sure at a time when the
show limits right right so when all is
said and done after you went through
these I mean we haven't gotten to the
Bill Clinton years who what impact did
Lew Wasserman have on Richard Nixon how
much did they get out of him besides the
network suit well they got the network
suit and they got ultimately the
investment tax credit which was a huge
thing which did mean billions to the
industry so I mean those are the most
important things that they got what ways
Lew Wasserman is relationship with Jimmy
Carter Wasserman wasn't close to Carter
he told me that he you know just Carter
wasn't his kind of a guy and I'm not
aware of anything great that Hollywood
got in the Carter years really it was it
was when Reagan came in that you know
that that Hollywood again got this huge
thing which was the fencin that was one
of the biggest things that that
Hollywood could get from Washington
Carter was I mean Wasserman supported
Carter but he wasn't really close to him
so what happened with MCA and Universal
Pictures on the way when they eventually
sold to the Japanese what were the
circumstances well it was ironic really
because Wasserman in his younger days
had been great at acquisition he had
built MCA as a talent agency in the in
the 40s by acquiring other agencies and
once the merger and acquisition boom
started in the mid 70s
Wasserman was you would think that he
would have been a great acquirer and
there was a it he should have been an
acquirer at that time because MCA was a
strong company and it could have grown
but it was a public company then it had
been a private company earlier he was
just able to make these deals in very
controlled environments and now is
somehow on the
the public arena he wasn't as good at it
he he didn't like to you know he
wouldn't really negotiate if he made an
offer it wasn't then gonna raise his
offer
he just wasn't nearly as a deft as a
public company in making acquisitions
and it may be to some people have
suggested that it was because the deals
he had made earlier were such incredible
deals when he had bought the Paramount
film library in 1958 for fifteen million
dollars which was then worth billions he
told me our when he acquired the
universe a lot for ten million dollars
or eleven million dollars I mean he had
done deals that were so spectacular some
people thought that maybe he couldn't
bring himself to do these sort of much
lesser deals later on in any event MCA
did not make the acquisitions that it
could have should have say in the 80s
considered Disney can post requiring
Disney had it done that everything would
have been different but didn't and so
ultimately MCA became a target because
it was just you know something that
somebody else could swallow and also MCA
was getting I mean massaman was getting
older and it wasn't clear it's sort of
seen by the late 80s that when he died
the company would be really vulnerable
and could be quickly acquired and broken
up so eventually 91 wasserman decided to
and the board went along to sell the
company to Matsushita this became
something that was a disaster for
Wasserman and for MCA the Mets Uche the
management didn't get along with
Wasserman even though the company had
been sold
Wasserman thought that he would still
rule which was kind of naive somebody
said to me only in Hollywood what do you
think that you could sell your company
and still have the autonomy that you had
before so he clashed with Matsuda and
eventually Matsuda sold it to Seagram
without even telling Wasserman that the
deal was in the works which was almost
an unimaginable thing people in
Hollywood
would not believe that okay he had sold
the company but he was still there he
was still running it they could not
believe that his company because they
still thought it was his company had
been sold out from under him without his
knowing it when was this picture taken
well that picture I'm not sure but I
mean it I would say it was like 96 or so
97 it was after the Seagram acquisition
Wasserman does not look very happy and
that who's he with he's with Edgar
Bronfman jr. and the relationship who
was mr. Brompton well he was the person
who had engineered the acquisition of
MCA by Seagram and he and Wasserman
never did have any kind of a
relationship Wasserman became chairman
emeritus he was still went to work every
day nobody consulted him Bronfman said
about sort of just trying to change the
company completely he wanted to do
everything different than the way
Wasserman had done that he was a
newcomer in Hollywood and seemed very
arrogant actually to think that he who
was a young man a newcomer he disparaged
everything was Herman it down it was not
a good attitude and eventually he failed
and the company was sold to Vivendi and
Wasserman was just I mean for Wasserman
who would built this you know giant
really to be there because he still came
to work every day through all these
transitions and just see the things sort
of being taken apart piece by piece
was extraordinarily painful he was
famous part of his legend that he had
created his persona was that he was
somebody who never made a mistake and I
was very surprised when I was talking to
him one day and he was recounting the
things he loved to recount his
acquisition of the Paramount film
library how great that was his
acquisition of Universal and then there
was a pause and he said now you want to
know the dumb thing I did which really
took my breath away because whilst
Herman was never supposed to say he
didn't done anything domine said you
know sold the company to the Japanese
and
who owns it today well today it's
Vivendi who well let's see Messier was
fired so I don't even remember who the
chairman of of India is today Barry
Diller has been at the helm at Universal
and they're trying to vendhya is trying
to sell it off and it'll be in pieces it
seems like pretty sure Edgar Bronfman
actually has reappeared trying to maybe
make a bid for some parts of it how long
did it take you to do this book five
years and what was the hardest part of
it the hardest part really was the
historic part because I had in my
previous books I was dealing with things
that were pretty much contemporary and
here trying to find out what had
happened in Chicago in the 20s and 30s
where there were very very few people
left who were alive then in positions
that they would have known anything that
was the hardest part but I was fortunate
to find some people who were alive and
also to find some you know oral
histories and archival material about
Capone's Chicago so that actually that
became one of my favorite parts of the
book where were you born in New Jersey
in a small town Carney you grew up in
that town or did you go to New York
immensely I grew up in that town well
and then West Orange my parents moved to
West Orange what'd your parents do my
father was a real estate person and my
mother a schoolteacher and where did you
go to school I went to Wellesley my
first two years and then I left and went
to Barnard finished up there and
Columbia Journalism school and how did
you get into this journalism business
what was your first job well after
Columbia Journalism I moved to
California and I started writing for the
San Diego reader which paid me ten
dollars for a story and then eventually
I graduated to things like human
behavior magazine which I remember paid
me $500 for a story on which I worked
for about six months my husband was
supporting me at that time obviously I
couldn't have worked for $10 for a story
and then I moved back to New York and
went to work
that's four year and then went to work
for zebra at the American Lawyer he had
just started the American Lawyer how
long were you there I was there for
about from about eighty to eighty eight
when I went to The New Yorker of all the
stuff you've written all the articles
which one got you the most controversy
well the Milken book was the most
predatory ocean predators ball was the
most controversial because Milken was
still very powerful at the time that I
wrote it he hadn't been indicted yet and
I said that he should be indicted he
didn't appreciate that
he and his people his lawyers tried to
stop the book from being published that
was the most controversial what's next
I'm back to The New Yorker happily
writing stories there I'm doing a
profile of Elliott Abrams at the moment
and why Elliott Abrams I think he's an
interesting person really interesting
person in an incredibly powerful
position at this moment his portfolio at
the NSA is the Middle East and it's
quite a moment to have the Middle East
portfolio is there any way to describe
your approach to journalism different
than others you have a special approach
to a special way to go about it I don't
think so I mean I do have this I do like
to try to tell a story a larger story
through an individual if I can and like
so many of my colleagues I try to write
narratives you know I'm a frustrated
fiction writer if I could write fiction
I'd write fiction since I can't write
fiction I look for characters whom a
novelist would covet yeah you touched on
it earlier but after this book what's
the big picture conclusion that you
reach at the end of this book well
Hollywood I mean there could never be
four years in Hollywood people would say
who's going to be the next Lew Wasserman
because he there was no one who aspired
to power in Hollywood who imagine being
anyone other than Lew Wasserman and by
the time whilst Herman died or even a
few years before it it was cleared
there would never be at least in the
foreseeable future there will not be
another Lew Wasserman because Hollywood
has changed so much and the way it is
today no one could exert the kind of
power that Wasserman did here's the
cover of the book when Hollywood had a
king as our guest just told us about Lew
Wasserman Connie Brooke thank you very
much for joining us